Second definition of terms if you like
is s or fast
as it's sometimes or mostly it's
translated in English. Um could you shed
some light on what are the implications
of the term fast or som
is Arabic word which is singular sam is
plural. Somam in Arabic is derived from
the word sama which means to abstain or
to restrain from the normal things
whether it be eating, drinking or
talking. And a person who observes some
or abstains from these thing is called
asim.
And this word is used in the Quran in
surah Mariam chapter number 19 verse
number 26. When the angel speaks to
Mary, may Allah be pleased with her who
is the mother of Jesus Christ peace be
upon him and this word is used and if
you read this word says that I have
vowed to fast to Allah
but here the meaning of the word ps fast
doesn't mean refraining from eating or
drinking it means refraining from
speaking because when we go to the
context when we read one verse before in
the Quran surah Mariam
Chapter number 19 verse number 25 it
says that Allah subhanaa tala says to
Mary may Allah be pleased with her that
shake the palm tree towards yourself and
the ripe dates will fall and the next
verse suram chapter 19 verse 26 says eat
and drink from them and then it says
that when you meet any human being tell
them I have vowed to fast for Allah and
I will not speak to any human
So because here it says about speaking
the word psalm used here means that to
abstain from speaking.
But the word s in Islamic terminology in
the Islamic Sharia it means a person who
does an act of worship
and with intention he does it for the
sake of Allahhana tala and he or she
abstains
from
eating, drinking or nourishment as well
as
from sexual intercourse or from lustful
Simmon ejaculation.
In short, the word som in Islam means a
person who abstains from the fast
breakers. And the fast breakers, the
things that break the fast are food
whether taken by mouth or by nose or
drink any kind of drink whether it be
water, milk, fruit juice, any drink
taken from mouth or nose or any
nourishment for the body taken from any
source
as well as abstaining from a sexual
intercourse.
In short, it means abstaining the
stomach and the private part. This is
what it means Islamically.
And
this is the basic meaning. But if you go
ahead with the broader meaning, it does
not mean only abstaining the stomach and
the sexual part from the things that
break the fast. It even means that along
with the fasting of the stomach and the
sexual parts, there is fasting of the
tongue.
of the eyes, of the ears and the other
limbs of the body. That is the reason
when we use the word psalm, our beloved
prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said, it's mentioned in say
Bkari volume number three in the book of
fasting had number 1903. Our beloved
prophet said that a person who does not
abstain does not leave false action and
false speech obsinity etc. Allah does
not require of him to abstain from food
and drink. That means beside abstaining
from food and drink, you also have to
abstain from false speech, false actions
etc. And this message is further
repeated. My beloved prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam. Our beloved prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said in the
say hadith of say volume number one had
number 1068. Above prophet said that a
person while fasting when he abstains
from food and drink he should also
abstain from false speech from obscene
language and if a person gets angry and
if he argues with him or fights with him
he should say I'm fasting I'm fasting
so if we look at it when a person fast
there are basically three things that he
should obtain from number one is the
stomach and the private parts. They
should abstain
from things that break the fast that is
food, drink and sexual act. The second
is that the other parts of the body, the
tongue, the eyes, the ears, the limbs,
even they should fast. Fasting of the
tongue means a person should abstain
from backbiting. Should abstain from
slandering, from telling a lie,
should abstain from gossiping, abstain
from rumor mongering,
abstain from vulgarity.
Fasting of the eyes means he should
abstain from looking at things which are
unlawful. Like when he says the nam he
should lower his gaze. He should not
watch unislamic movies or unislamic
things. Fasting of the years means he
should abstain from hearing things which
are haram, which are prohibited like
abstain from listening to music, abstain
from listening to songs which are
unislamic.
So this is the way how the other parts
of the body also fast. And the third
thing is the fasting of the heart and
the mind. They should abstain from
things which take away person from the
worship of Allah from the zikar of
Allah. So this overall is the meaning of
the word psalm.